welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is under attack well not from roided-out
space tyrants or Mysterio's big news
network
but from Hollywood legends mad at their
grandkids for watching an endgame three
times instead of shutter island' or The
Godfather Part 3 yes Martin Scorsese the
director behind Goodfellas taxi driver
Raging Bull and the wolf of Wall Street
called the Marvel films quote not cinema
in Francis Ford Coppola maker of The
Godfather films Apocalypse Now and lots
and lots of wine backed him up saying
Martin was being kind by calling it not
cinema and that he call it a tub of [ __ ]
just could he despicable was his word
beneath this seemingly petty squabble
between beloved wealthy filmmakers is
actually a fascinating truth about how
exactly the stories of Avengers endgame
spider-man and Nick Fury keeping that
one eye open and every damn movie have
transformed what kind of stories we now
expect on the big screen and how this
all foreshadows what kind of we heard
deep fakes will be seen on the big
screen in the next decade join me as I
explained the real reason Scorsese and
Coppola hates the MCU in this episode of
the inside Marble
[Music]
okay in early October while promoting
his upcoming Jimmy Hoffa film the
Irishman Scorsese said this about Marvel
films I don't see them I tried you know
but that's not cinema honestly the
closest I can think of them as well made
as they are with actors doing the best
they can under the circumstances is
theme parks it's not cinema of human
beings trying to convey emotional
psychological experiences to another
human being
shortly after this guardians of the
galaxy director James Gunn tweeted that
Scorsese is judging films he has not
seen the same way people protested
Scorsese's movie The Last Temptation of
Christ
not long after Robert Downey jr. told
Howard Stern I mean look it'd be like
saying Howard Stern isn't radio there's
a lot to be said for how these genre
movies and I was happy to be part of the
problem if there is one right it
denigrated the the the era the art form
of cinema and by the way when you come
in like a stomping Beast and you
eliminate the competition
in such a demonstrative way you know
it's it's phenomenal whatever he means
by that and then Sam Jackson was asked
about Scorsese's remarks on the red
carpet I love it I love it he actually
said this I mean that's like saying you
know bug money ain't funny
you know films are films everybody
doesn't like his stuff either you know I
mean we happen to but if everybody
doesn't you know there are a lot of
Italian Americans that don't think he
should be making films about them like
that so I mean everybody's got an
opinion okay
so the more recent update came from
Francis Ford Coppola just said Martin
was being kind when he said it wasn't
cinema he didn't say it was despicable
which is what I say oh damn somebody's
got to promise me this time James Gunn
went to Instagram to respond
meaning it's personal it's a 20-19
equivalent of going to mattresses for
you you pointed out how the older
generation hated Coppola gangster movies
as despicable replacements for the
westerns of John Ford and Sergio Leone
and finally during all this Scorsese
clarified his original comment and also
kind of doubling down saying right now
the theaters seemed to be mainly
supporting the theme park and he's in a
park comic book films they're taking
over the leaners and I think
can have those films it's fine it's just
that that shouldn't become what our
young people believe is cinema it just
shouldn't he described how young people
don't know enough about the all too
important history of Jimmy Hoffa as
well-known as he was time just wiped him
away this is a world we live in
our children are I don't know what
they're doing with those devices they
perceive reality differently also get
off my lawn also old man screens at
cloud okay I think you could tell by my
completely impartial intonation that I
obviously sided with the James gun camp
on this I mean who couldn't side with
that I love the work of Scorsese and
Coppola and I kind of see their points
but why do you gotta say these things
old men old it does is it turns the fans
against each other which is stupid
because the gangster movies of Scorsese
and Coppola are just as pettish eyes as
the Marvel movies are for every Marvel
fan boy there's a sanitation engineer in
Jersey who quotes Don Corleone as he
dumps a body in a trash compactor for
every overage spider-man cosplayer
there's a guy named spider who thinks
bill the butcher is the hero we need and
deserve and gun it's totally right that
at one point filmmakers like Scorsese
and Coppola were the newcomers ruining
everything people knew about Hollywood
and replacing it with their new
storytelling form that some people
considered despicable like in the 1960s
Hollywood movies were way smaller in
scale they were off in westerns where
musicals are Hitchcock slow-burn stories
that were weirdly tan-colored but in the
1970s Scorsese Coppola along with
Spielberg and George Lucas they changed
everything they were considered the new
wave of young filmmakers who
revolutionized Hollywood films to faster
paced two-hour-long capers with lots of
big action big violence big special
effects that costs a lot of money and
made a lot of money like these are the
guys who made Hollywood the billion
dollar business that it is today setting
the stage for Marvel to take over but
knowing this history explains why these
men are freaking out so much the massive
success of Kevin Feige with the MCU has
made them feel threatened for their way
of life in their storytelling style
because notice that Downey empathize
with them by describing Marvel Studios
as quote a stomping Beast eliminating
the competition in order to get
financing for his small period biopic
the Irishman Scorsese was likely in a
lot of conversations with various
producers about how increasingly
difficult it is to get a movie funded if
it isn't adapted from some pre-existing
well known
I pee Coppola is going through the same
thing apparently struggling to develop
his own big-budget passion project for
several years apparently about it utopia
named megalopolis
I'm sure it's gonna be a slam dunk the
Marvel Cinematic Universe began as an
exception to the established Hollywood
studio trend never made one movie
expecting it's gonna be part of a 23
movie series but because it's been so
successful it's now been adopted as the
rule I think about it pretty much every
movie franchise film now ends with a
post-credits scene that's designed to
set up some future installment that we
also have to go see Hobson Shaw had four
post-credit scenes yeah it's no longer
about the movie you're watching it's
about the bigger thing of what's coming
next
it is a lover of the simpler arts of the
cinema tradition yeah it probably sucks
for someone like Scorsese to see all the
stories he likes to tell now only have
homes on smaller screens leave things
like HBO and that's why Martin
Scorsese's descriptions of the Marvel
movies as theme parks makes a lot of
sense and why his statements about the
youth perceiving the reality differently
kind of accurately describe where this
is all heading the big studios of Disney
Warner Universal they now want the
experience of going to see a film
screening at your AMC or your Regal
Cinemas or your Arclight wherever you
see it to feel like a transported
process an immersive escape a different
reality than normal everyday media
consumption is because if you think
about all the profit that Disney makes
from the Marvel films and the Star Wars
films really just accounts for a
fraction that Disney makes from its
theme parks and its merchandise Disney
consider Star Wars Galaxies edge a place
where you pay and you go any ride rides
they link that in as a canonical
narrative experience that has a place on
the official Star Wars timeline of story
events the same is true for the upcoming
Marvel attraction at Disney parks and
yeah it all started with the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter
you can now walk into these narrative
timelines so maybe Scorsese is right and
saying the Marvel films aren't cinema
because yeah nowadays they're a hell of
a lot more than cinema they are
experiences that never end that are
designed to keep you in a state of
perpetual excitement and anticipation
the fact that the moviemaking business
evolves doesn't lessen the creative
achievements of Scorsese and Coppola in
fact that evolution is because of those
guys and that evolution led to a genre
with quite a bit of variation by the way
because it's not just it was you Joker
was a standalone comic book movie no
post-credits scene probably not
sequel but it still made a ton of money
and hey it helped that todd phillips did
it by taking inspiration from taxi
driver in the king of comedy two films
directed by Martin Scorsese and yes at
the end of the day all of these movies
that have mentioned in this breakdown
are cinema but hey I want to know what
you guys think do you think Scorsese and
Coppola have a point or should they just
shut up and let their grandkids play
with their spider-man toys
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram and twitter at a
boss and subscribe to new rockstars more
journeys deeper and deeper inside marvel
thank you for joining me and let's
collectively try to stay off of Coppola
and Scorsese's lawns
[Music]